you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact on a clear December night
in 1899 the SS war amou was quietly
cutting its way through the water of the
mid Pacific Ocean in the middle of the
trip between Vancouver to Australia
the captain gave some unusual orders the
pilot was told to stop the engine then
put it slightly in Reverse until the
ship's at perfectly still in the calm
water using the Stars and a compass
captain John Phillips and the navigator
checked and rechecked their location at
precisely midnight local time the war
amou lay exactly on the equator at
exactly the point where it crosses the
International Dateline the consequences
of this bizarre position were many the
forward part of the ship was in the
southern hemisphere in the middle of
summer while the stern was in the
northern hemisphere in the middle of
winter the date in the stern part of the
ship was December 30 1899 near the bow
it was January 1 1900 the ship was
therefore not only in two different days
two different months two different
seasons in two different years but also
in two different centuries all at the
same time
moreover the 32 passengers were cheated
out of New Year's Eve celebrations one
entire day December 31 1899 disappeared
from their lives for all time they
didn't seem to mind very much because
those on board the war memo became the
first people to greet the new century
did you know the Bible talks about a
lost day in history stay with his
friends were going to learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 number and
here it is again eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven that's 800
god says you know it just occurred to me
we've been on the air for so long now we
still have an 800 number everyone's got
these other numbers now but back when we
did it it was a toll-free number and now
they're all toll-free but yeah if you
got a Bible question one more time got
your pencil handy and give us a call we
get lines wide open right now we get the
one or two people standing by call us
with your Bible questions eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven as
800 God says my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening
listening France and we'd also like to
welcome those who are joining us on
Facebook I know we have a number of
folks who are joining us across the
country and around the world a very warm
welcome to you thank you for being part
of our Bible study and again it's past
that I've mentioned if you have a Bible
question the phone line to call is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven pastor Doug let's start the
program with prayer dear father in
heaven we thank you once again that we
have this opportunity to gather together
and open up your word and just study
thank you for your promise to be with us
in Jesus name Amen
amen pastor Hagee opened the program
with rather an amazing fact here is a
ship just so happens to be as the
century turns from the 1800's to the
1900s and he's in the very spot between
what did you say the northern hemisphere
the southern hemisphere but
between the the International Dateline
between one day and another day and the
ship was sort of divided up into these
four quadrants exactly if that's being
divided a quad me experienced you know
they didn't plan on doing it but on the
way to Australia one of the one of the
crew said captain do you realize how
close we're going to be to the Dateline
and the equator during our crossing and
during the change of the century and the
captain had a sense of humor II said
well let's just go a little bit out of
our way and make history and he did so I
understand Mark Twain was actually on
that ship another day he wasn't on the
ship that day but yeah the war amou you
know that lost day of history I was once
traveling March 8th to Australia and I
landed March 10th and I keep telling
Karen I'm actually you're younger than I
am because my birthday is March 9th and
there was no March 9th on that trip
because I just missed it on the date
line she doesn't accept my argument
though but there is biblically a day
that is often missing from people's
experience and you know you read about
it right there in the second chapter of
Genesis and the very beginning of the
Bible it says when God created the
heavens and the earth in six days why
don't we have seven days in a week he
was finished after six days he made one
more day to be a blessed holy day of
rest the time of worship of time of
recreation a time for fellowship with
our loved ones and other believers and
that's a day that in this busy society
is often forgotten and neglected by a
lot of people and they miss that
blessing that God has promised he
promised to bless that day and we have a
free offer where people can learn about
that blessing and receive it and when
they read this I hope they'll share it
with their friends
yes it's an amazing fact study guide
that's called the last day of history
talks about this special time that God
had set it aside for worship and to
remember him being as I our creator a
very important study it's free we'll be
able to send it to anyone who calls and
asks again the number to call is 800
four six three seven two nine seven and
you can ask for the study guide called
the last day of history ready to go to
the phone lines our first caller this
evening is Bill listening in Chicago
bill welcome to the program hi John how
are you
good I thank you for calling and your
question is the Bible thing about use of
medical marijuana yeah well let me
repeat this because I think you're
you're not real close to your phone or
there's some drop out but the question
is does the Bible address medical
marijuana of course the word marijuana
is nowhere in the scripture and you know
you don't find tobacco in the scripture
there's a lot of herbs in plants that
aren't mentioned specifically so really
the question is is it appropriate at
some time to use medicine now most
people if marijuana is kind of a hot
topic part in the pun these days because
a lot of people started claiming they
were using marijuana for medicinal
purposes but it seemed like everybody
had a backache I know that in Mendocino
County I actually got some property
pastor Ross has been there with me he'll
testify don't grow but it's called the
Emerald triangle up there with Mendocino
County Trinity Shasta County they grow
much of the marijuana in North America
seem like all the neighbors all of a
sudden had needed medical marijuana but
a lot of it was to grow in to sell there
are some people who are using the
medicinal value of tetrahydrocannabinol
just like you know aspirin comes from
the bark of a tree and there's a lot of
drugs that are originally most drugs I
think come to some sort of plant so if a
person is using the drug genuinely
prescribed by a doctor for some real
medical value you know there's nothing
wrong with that Bible the Bible talks
about the leaves of different plants are
for healing but when people start doing
it habitually the use of any drug
habitually is not good usually a drug is
used to bitterly because another problem
is being neglected now I'm not a doctor
I'm just
sharing that so that's the principle but
I also want to have everyone recognize
the reality not everybody with a medical
marijuana card really has a medical
problem and if they're smoking it it's
probably doing them more harm than good
so there's a principle you know Bible
talks about the herb of the field could
be used for different things when just a
couple of strange examples one when Leah
thought that she was infertile her son
brought some Mandrake's which was a
plant and bingo she had a baby so I
don't know if there's any value in that
but they did believe in using herbs for
different things in the Bible on
occasion but not habitually so I hope
that helps a little bit and we
appreciate your question bill we do have
a book called God's free health plan
that talks about some of the health
principles you'll find in the Bible yes
we'll be able to sing that to anyone who
calls and asks the number is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven that's actually the phone line
here to the studio but if you'd like to
get that free resource called 883 five
six seven four seven that is our
resource phone line and you can ask for
the study guide called God's free health
plan some biblical principles for health
our next call is June listening from
Spokane Washington June welcome to the
program hi there how are you guys
hi good thanks for calling so I wanted
to know where in the New Testament does
it say that we should continue to keep
the service that's interesting you would
ask that I was just talking to pastor
Ross about that before we went on the
air well there's a multiple places first
of all when a young man came to Jesus he
said good master what shall I do that I
might have eternal life and he can find
this in mark chapter 10 and in Matthew I
can't remember the verse in Matthew rich
young ruler Jesus said keep the
commandments he said which ones Jesus
began to quote from the Ten Commandments
now some have said well because the
Sabbath is not specifically mentioned in
the New Testament you shouldn't keep it
but in reality the commandment thou
shalt not take the name of the Lord in
vain third commandment is nowhere in the
New Testament
so what Christian would say
it's okay to use the Lord's name in vain
and I do believe that the Sabbath is in
the New Testament here's an example when
Jesus dies on the cross
it says they wouldn't finish in bombing
his body and this is Luke 23 they would
not finish in bombing his body but they
went home and kept the Sabbath according
to the commandment and then it says in
acts chapter 13 and on the Sabbath day
we went out of the city I'm sorry I
think it's act 16 on the Sabbath day we
went out of the city by a river where
prayer was want to be made Hebrews
chapter 4 says there remains the keeping
of a Sabbath for the people of God Jesus
Susie Matthew 24 pray that your flight
be not in winter neither on the Sabbath
day yeah so there there's just a lot of
scriptures in the New Testament there's
a lot of debate that Jesus had with the
religious leaders about the Sabbath he
would heal on the Sabbath and there'd be
you know big discussion but never did
Jesus say the Sabbath should not be kept
in all of those debates he talks about
how it should be kept
he never said you don't keep he said the
Son of Man is Lord also of the Sabbath
day and Jesus said I have kept my
father's Commandments oh Jesus kept it
it says the custom of Christ as his
custom was he entered into the synagogue
on the Sabbath day and stood up to read
the scriptures and that's Mark chapter I
might even mark chapter 2 or 1 getting
old and the numbers I get dyslexic but
Matt that's actually in two verses I
believe the custom of Christ so Luke
4:16 yeah there you go
and are those enough to get you started
or would you like a study guide on that
yes I would like that that'd be great
we'll be happy that we have a study
guide matter of fact the one we offered
tonight yes last day in history would be
a great resource
just call 883 five six seven four seven
you can ask for the study guide called
last day in history we also have a
website called simply Sabbath truth com
Sabbath truth comm you can read the
study guide for free online at the
website along with a lot of additional
information on the subject just Sabbath
truth com thank you we appreciate your
call June god bless great thank you
next caller that we have is Jerry
listening from
bargain Jerry welcome to the program yes
good evening passengers said Doug and
Ross my question pertains to the
practice of providing feedback or rating
vendors for online purchases I recently
ran into one that was extremely poor the
quality the product was misrepresented
the communications demonstrated extreme
surliness by the seller now I'm to rate
that individual and future users will
will rely on the ratings but we're asked
to forgive and turn the cheek so you can
see the predicament I'm in that's a good
principle in our relationships with
other people
you should be as merciful as you can be
but you know it's not wrong to give an
honest evaluation here's an example an
employee from let's suppose I'm a
business owner and I've got an employee
and that employee is not a good employee
and the employee is fired or quits or
whatever and he goes and apply somewhere
else well the new employer calls us and
they say look can you give a reference
if I say all this guy's just great well
that's not being Christian that's being
dishonest you've got to give an honest
objective you shouldn't be unkind but
you should give an honest subjective
evaluation in fairness to the new
employer so he knows what he's getting
into
so you know as a Christian you want to
love people and if people are gonna buy
this product and you realized boy that
was a bad experience I should be honest
with folks and let them know don't you
don't have to be negative and
hypercritical but just say you know
here's the facts and you're just sharing
truth with people I bought the product I
had these expectations in it it failed
and I was very disappointed that's being
honest and you know what that does that
makes the vendor improve their quality
and everybody benefits so there's no
moral dilemma there you see what I'm
saying okay well yeah that's kind of why
I was thinking but again it's it's it's
not gonna be a good question yeah okay
thank you very much appreciate that
Gerry thank you I don't think we
have a question but that's a good
question you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast call 885 six seven four
seven once again that's 800 eight three
five six seven four seven next photo
that we have is Rudy listening from San
Bernardino California
Rudy welcome to the program Thank You
pastors yes how can we help you tonight
my question is I remember reading a
believer the Old Testament where I can't
remember who it was that they said about
the sudden standing still and going back
yeah you've got two episodes where the
Sun was altered one is in the book of
Joshua chapter 10 and then you have an
experience that is with King Hezekiah
where the son went backwards in Joshua's
story the son simply paused and it it
just seemed like it stood still for
nearly a day while the Israelites
pressed a battle for 24 hours with some
of the other Canaanites it was a long
battle they were winning Joshua saw that
if they didn't finish the battle and and
completely rout the enemy they'd have to
find another day and he prayed the son
might stand still and it did that's
different than when Hezekiah prayed and
I think that's Isaiah 39 is one place
it's into the story of Isaiah and the
son is in I think I think it's in might
be three places might be in second kings
and chronicles Andy and Isaiah
thirty-nine but he prays and are I
should say Isaiah praise after healing
Hezekiah the son goes backward ten
degrees which is I think about it's like
20 minutes on the sundial so that was
observed by even Babylonian astronomers
that then came to Jerusalem to ask if
they knew about what caused this wonder
in the heavens
so you do have that story happens twice
in the Bible or something connected with
the Sun maybe do you have more about
that Rudy you were asking about the that
story yeah well I had an astronomy class
one time and the person teaching the
class was mentioned that something about
how in the celestial calendar or
timeframe that that's annotated somehow
you know that is from what I've heard
that is a rumor they say that you know
ancient astronomers say there was a day
missing I've not seen any hard data on
that it's sort of like a you know
Christian wives tale that keeps getting
repeated
it sounds good and encourages people but
it's not I've never seen data on that
well by the way the two verses about
Hezekiah and the son going backwards
would be second Kings 21 to 11 the other
one I think is Isaiah chapter 38 so I
believe it happened and it's it's
recorded like I said not only by in the
Jewish Scriptures but the Babylonians
responded to that and so it was
something that was observed now there
are there are traditions you know
sometimes something true in the Bible
ends up making its way into legends and
other cultures there are other cultures
that have legends that were based on
this story in the Bible and it's like
the Bible talks about a flood where all
the wicked were destroyed well you get
the Greek legend of Atlantis so some of
these other legends are based on a
biblical truth that is an older truth
all right well thanks for your Cole Rudy
Onix holy is o'neil listening in North
Carolina
Oh Neal welcome to the program Hey yes
and your question what the Bible says
about the sale of unclean foods about
the sale of unclean foods
yes well if you're if you're a believer
God does not want us consuming unclean
foods and I would think you would not
want to be involved in buying or selling
something that God says you shouldn't
eat for the benefit of others
eating it that sort of would you know
it's like I know Christians that
sometimes they end up finding themselves
at a supermarket where they've got to be
a cashier and the liquor and the
cigarettes are going through and they
cringe whenever it happens I mean they
also got celery and lettuce but so I
think Christians want to avoid being put
in a situation where we're dispensing
something we don't believe in so I don't
know if that's answering what you're
asking yes now there might be a bit of a
distinction as past that I've mentioned
if someone is working in a grocery store
they're not the ones choosing what
product is being carried but one of the
products that might be carried is
something unclean food let's say for
example and he just simply no stacking
the shelf or you a cashier that's a
little different than if you own the
store and you actually choosing what to
buy and sell so I think there is a
distinction there yeah and I'm trying to
think of some scriptures that you know
we need to avoid the appearance of evil
and if we're telling someone not to do
something we wouldn't want to be buying
it or selling it for others yeah I know
I I know someone that was trying to help
a senior citizen and they asked them to
say look I'm too old to go to the market
here's my list can you get this for me
and they said well sure and they looked
at the listens and wow I never eat that
yeah no but yeah they're trying to help
do a loving thing for a neighbor
sometimes you want to do the loving
thing you buy their pork and beans
alright hey thank you very much for your
question thanks to me on my next color
that we have is Lee listening in
Colorado Lee welcome to Bible answers
live all right thank you for having me
yeah my question is my husband is an
abusive husband or physically and harsh
words but I love him so much
I said okay to the for everybody this is
not a good relationship but I want to
keep the relationship with him I want to
win his soul for God let me ask this
question Lee are you wanting the
relationship to get better yeah where
this doesn't happen anymore if you want
the relationship to
better there is another option between
enduring abuse or divorce and that would
be separation explain to your husband
look I'm gonna separate from you until
you get counseling and that you don't
want to be living in that situation
anymore and until he gets counseling you
know he's gonna have to find another
place you're gonna find another place to
let him know you're serious
but it I don't think it's God's will
for I mean you know the Lord feels very
strongly about marriage and wanting
marriages to stay together but I don't
think it's God's will for any spouse to
be a punching bag and even verbal abuse
can be you know a very very demeaning
vitriolic so you might have to practice
some tough love and tell them to get
some counseling yeah
don't you think that God wants us to
forgive and help people like that
absolutely forgive but forgiving doesn't
mean that you have to stay in a
situation where you're being physically
abused part you can you you know let me
give you an example I've got some people
have done business with and I don't
think they were very fair they took
advantage of me well I forgave them I'm
not doing business with them anymore so
you you know you may forgive your
husband but you need to say what you're
doing is wrong now do you think that a
man don't you want your husband to be
saved yeah you want your husband to be
saved right yeah is he a Christian it's
a believer well if he's a believer part
of that would be a love your wife and
you don't love by being rough with
people and so if you want him to be
saved the loving thing for you to do for
his salvation he's got to repent of that
sin he's not going to until you you make
him realize it's not acceptable and you
may need to you know explain to him
first what you're gonna do say look
you've gotta promise me you're never
gonna do this again if you do I'm
separating until you get counseling
actually I'm now I've been away from him
for two months but then you say
but then he he's back to his pet habit
to alcohol and configuration this or
this there's another problem there yeah
well you know what I recommend this is a
kind of question that you probably don't
want us to be dealing with in detail on
a Bible answer program you need to find
a local pastor where you attend or a
counselor and you need to get some
counsel Lee and hopefully your your
husband will join you and he can
hopefully find a victory over the one
problem maybe leading to the other you
know we do have a study guide that is
called keys to a happy marriage it lays
out some very important principles if
you haven't had a chance to read that
I'd encourage you to call and ask for
that and we'll send that to you and then
as pastor Doug says in these type of
specific instances it's probably good to
seek counsel from a good pastor who can
who can guide you through this
experience mm-hmm it is tough keep it in
prayer keep trusting in the Lord and and
he'll guide you the number to call again
is 883 five six seven four seven and you
can ask for that study guide called
keys to a happy marriage and I think
you'll find some of the principles and
they're very helpful I think our next
caller that we have is Jerry and he's
listening from Alberta Jerry welcome to
the program we have just a few minutes
yeah yes I was just so so impressed with
the answer that you brought because I
was just mentioning that exact slogan
that you know marriage will succeed if
you do it God's Way yeah
and you know tolerance is one thing
abuse
I would rather somebody hit me then you
know emotionally scar me because they
don't know yeah
now hey Jerry we're gonna run out of
time before you get to your question yes
for a great about who do you guys
consider the bear in Revelation a great
question yeah in Revelation chapter 13
it talks about a beast that is partly
like a bear and that is based on Daniel
chapter 7 it appears in Daniel 7 first
yea the first verses there
to the berries of course Daniel chapter
7 and there the bear represents the
medo-persian Empire it rose up after
Babel and Babylon is represented by the
lion so you have the bear which is Meeta
Persia followed by the leopard which is
Greece followed by the dragon like
beasts which is pagan Rome and there's
some parallels of course in Revelation
as well because it covers these same
themes so the bear is Daniel chapter 7
and it references me to Persia
let's get those three ribs in the mouth
which represent the kingdoms of Libya
Lydia Egypt Egypt and Syria very good
hey friends don't go away we're just
this is our mid time break we've got two
more Bible questions coming and we're
gonna start with a run in just a moment
and you can also be checking us out on
Facebook right now
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website at amazing facts dot o-r-g
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into satan the arch
villain the birth of evil a rebellion in
heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation and even discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
earth every life the cosmic conflict if
God is good if God is all-powerful if
God is love
then what went wrong if you've missed
any of our amazing facts programs visit
our website at amazing facts org there
you'll find an archive of all our
television and radio programs including
amazing facts presents one location so
many possibilities amazing facts org
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
you like what you see and what you hear
click share and pass it around we just
we take Bible questions from people who
are listening through Facebook as well
as those on the phone my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross we have
ginger is listening from Nebraska ginger
welcome to the program hello how are you
good
and your question tonight my question is
either in a sermon that you had pastor
Doug or on your last Bible answers live
program you said there would be no
children in heaven so would that mean my
grandfather and granddaughter if they go
to heaven would be the same age oh no I
don't think I've ever said there's no
children in heaven I think maybe what
people heard me say and I'm reading the
words of Jesus that there are no new
marriages in heaven
jesus said they do not marry nor are
they given in marriage he's very
explicit but the in the resurrection of
course are gonna be children alive when
Jesus comes that are translated there
will be children who are resurrected
that died while they were children or
babies and and they'll be placed back in
their mother's arms and there's some
verses in the Bible that for instance
Malachi chapter 4 talks about them going
forth and growing up and you read in
Isaiah as at chapter 11 where the child
will little child will lead them and the
child will play the nursing child will
play on the whole of the venomous
serpent and Isaiah 11 yeah and then you
read where is it where it says children
will play in the streets of the New
Jerusalem that's as if and I are I think
so there's a number of verses to talk
about children being in heaven the thing
is you don't hear about the new
marriages and new births in the kingdom
so does that help a little okay that
makes sense oh no yeah now they will not
stay children forever though they'll
ultimately grow up and and no well when
you get to heaven you say well grandma
and grandpa everybody all be the same
age people have lived longer lives in
this white life were are going to take
that gravitas with them to the new body
that God gives them so
they will somehow have more experience
but they will not look old
they'll be forever youthful but that
with more experience alright I mix color
that we have thank you for calling
ginger we have I think it's as here or
as here from Folsom California hi better
dog hi how can we help you today
our question like out we go to it either
alright well the question is why can't
we go to the movies or the theaters and
people have probably heard me say before
in my evangelistic programs that I think
it's a better witness if Christians do
not go to the traditional movies most
movies for one thing they're they're not
rated in a way that it would honor God
the Bible talks about the entertainment
of the world typically is not good
it doesn't mean you could never see
something good that's been produced
based on facts produces videos so
there's some good videos you can watch
usually when you go to the theater
you're paying a lot more for it it's not
always the best environment an example
would be you know you can buy orange
juice as here in a supermarket or you
can buy orange juice at a bar where they
sell alcohol they've also orange juice
you don't want to get your orange juice
at a bar it's not a good environment it
doesn't look like a good witness if you
walk in there and you're gonna pay way
too much for it so if there is an
occasional good movie or video that
comes out if you can wait until it comes
out on I used to say video DVD now and
you can watch it in your home a lot
cheaper I don't think it's good for
Christians to go to the typical movies
does that make sense yeah all right you
got another question yeah why can't we
celebrate Halloween well Christians
typically there's a lot of you know good
things first to celebrate Thanksgiving
is a great holiday for Christians a
number of Christians think it's
wonderful to remember the birth of
Christ or the resurrection of Christ and
they do that
or Christmas some disagree with that
because of the pagan trappings but a lot
of Christians recognize that if there is
a holiday associated with diabolical and
devilish things Halloween with all the
dead bodies and the ghosts and the
witches and the bones and the graves and
and you know if you don't give me a
treat I'll give you a trick it just
doesn't have the Spirit of Christ about
it and so if there's one holiday tell
all the TV channels are full of death
movies and scary movies and blood and
gore if there's one holiday Christian
should probably avoid the Bible says in
Ephesians we should avoid the unfruitful
works of darkness Halloween is a holiday
of darkness and I don't think Christians
should celebrate that I don't think it
makes Jesus happy that's why and thank
you very much for your question I
appreciate that
I mix well there we have is June
listening in California June welcome to
the program hi abetters hi and your
question yeah my question is this uh I
also pass out what this one pastor and
he says Hawaii the youth are leaving the
church and he says well you just need to
make the the church more modern or
contemporary what do you think about
that well that's not been our experience
pastor Ross and I pastor a church we've
got a very strong youth program we found
what the youth really want is they want
depth of meaning for worship to believe
in God they want teaching that gives
them a purpose for their lives the idea
that you're going to keep them in church
by entertaining them with music that
sounds like the music of the world but
you just throw in some Christian words
we've not seen that that's successful
and even if it was successful I don't
think it's the right way to do it the
Bible talks about teaching the young the
Word of God Deuteronomy chapter 6 says
teach your children when they lay down
when they rise up when they walk down
the way put the Word of God on the door
of your house so I it really it depends
on the parents as much as anything that
there is morning and evening worship
that you surround your kids with the
Word of God and they will grow up
believing okay so you think about the
Mormon
maybe maybe not to to very contemporary
just a little bit modern do you think
that's a better idea well the word this
there's nothing wrong with being modern
you know in our church we use electric
lights for years they use candles when
they came up with electric lights we
said hey well this is a good idea let's
use them and we use projectors and so
people can see the words on the screens
and they can see the scriptures up there
that I'm sharing they got it in their
Bible they get the music words in their
hymnal they can also see it and so using
technology and doing things in a modern
way there's nothing wrong with that I
think we should use all kinds of
innovative methods to reach young people
and old people we're using the internet
right now and we're using computers and
media and radio mm-hmm but I don't think
you need to sacrifice Krim principles
and start using worldly music and
worship styles so that your worship
program sounds like pandemonium
hootenanny and you just yeah so yeah
there should be a reverence there and I
think that's the important thing you
know I think we may see that used to
have a book about drums and worship and
worship and music and they can find that
on our website I think they could read
it for free just go to the amazing facts
website just amazing facts to RG and
click on the free library and I think
the book pdf version of the book is
available talking about worship
different types of worship what does the
Bible say so that'll be helpful annex
color that we have is I think it's
Lowe's listening from California loves
welcome to the program or lose well yeah
hi yes hi and your question the question
is you said we are saved by grace alone
yes we are saved by grace alone where do
the following obeying the Ten
Commandments come in with that faith
because Jesus when when we see how much
Jesus loves us the Bible says we love
Him because He first loved us when we
see that he died to save us
and we are saved by His grace through
faith in Him that we want to keep his
law and Jesus said if you love me keep
my Commandments and so if we love the
Lord we're gonna want to obey Him and if
a person says I believe it's in first
John if someone says I love the Lord and
he doesn't keep his Commandments he's a
liar and the truth is not in them so the
evidence that you love the Lord is you
obey can you give me that text please
yeah we can give you several first of
all I mean just the one pastor that
mentions John 14:15 this is Jesus he
said if you love me keep my Commandments
John 14:23 jesus said if anyone loves me
he will keep my word and then John 14 24
Jesus says he who does not love me does
not keep my word so it's pretty clear
that here Jesus talks about genuine love
for him will be manifest in obedience
obedience to His commandments and Jesus
kept the father's Commandments and the
commandments or the example given to us
by Christ is that we ought to also keep
God's commandments absolutely and now we
have a book on that we can share with
love on the written in stone well it
explains the law and faith you know what
would even be better is the book does
God's grace blot out his law and you
know we could recommend if you would
like a free copy loves if you call the
number that pastor Ross is gonna share
or you can go to the website you can we
can provide that book and the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the book called does God's grace blot
out the law the number is 883 five six
seven four seven we've got Jessica
listening from Florida Jessica welcome
to the program hi thank you hi I am
caught because I have a question about
first Corinthians chapter 14 that talks
about the gifts of tongues now I
understand there is a difference between
what happened at Pentecost with the
different languages that it talks about
specific verbal languages that were
spoken but I was reading over you know
fourth Corinthians fourteenth and it
seemed that there is a heavenly Lane
which between God and I so I just wanted
a little bit more clarity on that just
to see if we're headed in the bomb
headed in my direction or if I'm
incorrect or if I'm interpreting that
incorrectly you know you're asking a
great question when I first became a
Christian at about 17 or 18 and I began
to worship with my charismatic brothers
and sisters they were all speaking in
tongues and I couldn't understand what
was going on because when I read in the
book of Acts it's very clear that these
are known languages that they were given
the ability to speak but then you read
in the first Corinthians 14 and he talks
about what's going on in the church in
Corinth and I saw it very different from
what was happening in my church for
instance Paul says in 1st Corinthians 14
verse 5 he said he who speaks in a
tongue just edifies himself and then he
goes on to say so likewise verse 9
unless you utter by the tongue words
easy to be understood how will it be
known what is spoken for you're speaking
into the air Paul says I'd rather speak
five thousand words in that you
understand
I rather speak a few words that you
understand that ten thousand an unknown
tongue and so through the whole chapter
he he says do not speak in tongues
unless you have an interpreter that's
verse 13 let whom speaks in a tongue
pray that he might interpret just came
back from Spain last week and while I
speak a little Spanish not enough to
preach so while I was preaching I'd say
a few words I'd pause my translator
would interpret translate and so what
was happening in the Corinthian church
is there all these different language
groups because it was a city filled with
a lot of Roman slaves from all over the
Empire they spoke many languages the
services were becoming confusing people
were getting up and speaking in
languages that were unknown to others
there and he said look you're better off
speaking in a tongue that they can
understand and you know I think the
context of that is made quite clear in
verse 10 where Paul says is the first
Corinthians 14
says there are it may be so many kinds
of languages in the world and none of
them is without significance therefore I
do not know the meaning of the language
I shall be a foreigner to him who speaks
and he who speaks will be a foreigner to
me so the context of what Paul is saying
is there are many languages and if you
have people speaking a language that
nobody else knows and the word language
can also be translated tongue
it doesn't edify the congregation it you
know they're speaking to themselves they
speaking in the wind as it describes it
yeah go ahead I'm sorry what about
chapter 2 where inside that there there
are speaking an unknown tongue unto men
but unto God for no man understandeth
him that's what is where I'm kind of
hung up on that because I understand
again the difference between languages
verbal languages with different
countries and different group but
there's where it kind of goes a little
bit into more it's just like a
one-on-one well let me give you an
example of what Paul's talking about if
right now I should say borrow haha or
annoy elohenu melech ha'olam most
Electra men Awards I'm speaking to God
that's a Jewish prayer I'm not speaking
to men nobody understands me but that's
a real language it's Hebrew so this is
exactly what Paul's talking about now
you know what I always think it's
important to ask Jessica where in the
Bible do you see an example of people
speaking in a language that they don't
understand and nobody around them
understands what is the purpose of God
giving us a language that we speak that
we don't understand the purpose of
language is to communicate thought why
would God give us a language we don't
understand when God cursed the people at
Babel they couldn't understand each
other at Pentecost God reversed the
curse and he gave the disciples the
ability to speak in languages that
people understood can I offer you a free
book on the subject that I wrote
absolutely
it's and I really hope you'll read it
anyone listening to this dialogue right
now that's listening to the program will
be happy to send it to you you can read
it for free it's a book called
understanding
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks all you left
to do is call the number eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the book called
understanding tongues I'll be happy to
send that out to anyone who calls and
asks next for that we have is Hannah
listening in Wisconsin Hannah welcome to
the program hello
hi thank you for your patience and your
question yeah I am wondering about women
pastors I am trying to deal with this
but I just can't bring it out of my
mouth to say pastor you know Joan and
pastor Jim and I just i but it just
seems like it's a phenomena and in this
last century because when I've done any
research it started in the nineteen
fifties where the first woman pastor was
ordained in the United States and I go
back to first Timothy 3 Titus 1 and
pastors all tell me that was just
cultural that's the only thing they'll
say to me is that was just cultural and
most of the pastors I talked to are very
much like if it's in the word I believe
it so it's it is what it is but when it
comes to this they don't agree yeah well
you know I think I would have to agree
with you I think what's cultural is
what's happening right now with the
blurring of sexual distinctions in our
society who can deny that in the last
you know 30 years people have become
very nebulous about the distinction
between boy and girl and men and women
in a broad spectrum the very same
arguments that are often used for women
pastors are the same arguments that are
being now used that it was just cultural
in the Bible when God said homosexuality
and same-sex marriage was wrong they
said well that was just a culture back
then I agree with RC sproule who
recently passed away when he said that
in his opinion the push for women to be
ordained as pastors is not driven by
Scripture he said it was
100% driven but by the cultural changes
right now if you read in the Bible there
is no example of a woman serving than
the capacity of a priest no woman was
ever ordained as a king there was no
woman that was chosen as an apostle and
all the elders were men in the Bible and
so you know if you want to go by the
Bible it's pretty clear God made a
difference between men and women now
there is lots of opportunity for
ministry for women in the Bible and you
have women who are prophets in the Bible
but you don't ever see a woman offering
sacrifice or doing the functions of a
priest um don't you think that that this
has been allowed into the church that's
caused so much negative in the church
right now well I'll tell you Hannah let
me tell you one more thing and I
probably can't be labor this because we
have folks lined up but all you've got
to do is look at a history of nothing
else every single church that has
started compromising on this meaning the
Presbyterians the Methodists the
Lutheran's the episcopal x' they're
their numbers have plummeted their
numbers have been cut in half
the idea that ordaining women now to be
pastors is somehow going to be the
panacea that will grow the church
historically has proven an abysmal
failure it doesn't work whereas the
Southern Baptist who said we want to
stick with the Bible they're the largest
Protestant denomination in North America
so you know I think that Jesus and
you'll know by the fruits this doctrine
is not growing the church I think then
it's not popular but there needs to be a
biblical distinction in the roles of men
and women hey I've got a free book I can
send you and we do need to go to another
caller and it's called women in ministry
it's one of our gift books we can send
it to you you can read it online for
free then I'm gonna Coley's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and again the book is called woman
in ministry we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks we have Anna
who is listening from New York Anna
welcome to the program hi hi coppers hi
my coach was doing oh no problem
my question is why do you think God
created Adam before Eve well yeah
following up on that last question some
people say that God creates his best
work for last and that he made man and
then he said I think I can do better
my argument is when you look at creation
you see that God makes everything in
order of its complexity he doesn't make
the plants which are more complex than
the earth and the water until the third
day and then he makes the animals on the
on the sixth day and he makes the birds
in the fish and he makes the most
complex thing which is a woman I know
really well I what I mean by that they
are complex oh you're married to one so
much but even a woman's body has three
or four functions that a man's body
doesn't have they're very complex you
think of the chemical changes that take
place for childbirth it's a phenomenal
thing and so not to mention the brains
talking to each other both sides of the
brain but I think that God really wanted
to enhance the love relationship of man
and woman God wanted Adam to know he was
incomplete without Eve that's why he
named all the animals and he realized
hey you know I'm missing something I
can't communicate with the animals the
way I want to express myself and share
the paradise I'm in I just heard a man
talk about that he made an epic trip
across Europe on a train and it was so
wonderful he said the best thing was he
was alone he saw so many things but
there was no one to say look at that
look at that and he just it just kind of
took the joy out of it so God gave man
as someone who would complete him in a
woman that's a long answer I don't know
if it helped yes it did
thank you all right hey thanks a lot
appreciate your question we've got Jill
listening in Michigan Jill welcome to
the program thank you how you doing good
thank you for calling oh you're welcome
thanks taking my call I got it kinda I
guess probably a simple question okay so
you guys not for me but I want to get
back in church I've been really kind of
not
into the church seeing so much just my
personal life kind of things going on
but I want to know I've experienced like
a non-denominational that's where I've
been going to recently and then before
that I got saved like in Apostolic
Church years before and I want to know
what is the best Church I don't know if
this is well maybe it's not that easy
but I want to know what kind of church
should I go to because I don't know if I
need to go to church with an altar call
because where I'm going now they don't
have an altar call they will pray with
you but I just want to be in the right
church because I feel like time is short
and just I guess what I use very good
great question
hey I tell you what I'm gonna give you
an answer but then I want you to follow
up okay exactly yeah I'm gonna send you
a study guide because I want your answer
to be based on the Bible and it's called
the Bride of Christ and if you do this
and one more while I think yes that's
good the broad search search rules have
a book called the search for the true
church that I think you'll find
interesting go free
and so make sure and ask for those Jill
pastor Ross is gonna give you the
information yeah the number is 883 five
six seven four seven and call and ask
for the the study guide called the Bride
of Christ as well as the book called the
search for the true church and pastor
Doug in the next few seconds there's
some basic principle that I think a
person needs to bear in mind when they
are looking for a church yeah did you
want me to talk about those yeah yeah if
you want a church that's gonna be based
based on the scripture and that you're
gonna be saved by faith in Jesus and
that they're gonna be teaching the the
full everlasting gospel that you'd be
finding in in the in the Gospels the
right balance of faith love and
obedience you know you don't hear much
about holiness these days we do appeals
don't do altar calls every week we do
appeals at our church almost every week
and I think it's important to invite
people to come to Christ especially if
you see visitors or in the house you
never know
so do send for those that free offers
Jill I think that'll really bless you
alright well it's not a hard study it'll
your question very quickly we try not to
like get on the air and just promote a
particular denomination we want people
to study the word and listening friends
we just got a few seconds left before
this part of the program is going to
wrap up I want to remind you that
there's so much more information macing
facts Bible answers live is something we
do once a week but amazing facts
produces TV programs all week long
and that we've just got gobs and tons of
programming you can see on national
television networks as well as the radio
programs go to the amazing facts website
it's very simple amazing facts dot o-r-g
if you're blessed donate thank you for
listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love and great sacrifice but
behind them is another hero hidden in
plain sight amid the shadows he was
there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry shadows of light seeing Jesus
in all the Bible get your copy today by
calling
[Music]
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to seventy five terror
attacks natural disasters political
instability and global economic meltdown
these are the images people generally
associate with the tribulation and the
day of the Lord but did you know the
Bible speaks about another day of the
Lord just before the great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 in six
days God created the heavens and the
earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth com if you'd
like to enhance your study of God's Word
visit our website at WWF ag0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out